-This spring, see the story
of the black woman who became
a world-renowned scientist,
an accomplished cellist,
and activist,
and a man who was white
while she did it.
[ Laughter ]
-Her mic was too high,
but I fixed it.
It's fixed because of me.
[ Whispers ]
You're doing great.
-"White Savior."
It's about all the things
white people love
in movies about racism,
like that scene
where they're in the bar
and the white person sticks up
for the black person.
-This bar don't serve
people like you.
-I have just as much a right
to be here --
-Hey...
she's with me.
-Oh! Sorry about that, Jack.
-That's all right, bubba.
How are the kids?
-Good.
They're good.
Good.
-Great.
[ Laughter ]
-That thing where
a white person works closely
with a black person
and is surprised
to learn they're smart.
-Oh, my God.
You did it.
-Well, I've always been
pretty good at math.
-Well, you should go
to school for it.
-I did.
-You should get a job in it.
-I have one.
-You do?
Where?
-Here.
I'm your boss.
-You?!
[ Chuckles ] Wow.
-Now clean this up
and get me a coffee.
-No.
-There's also the part
where the black person
very calmly eviscerates
a white person
in a way that makes
white audiences think,
that was the day
racism was solved,
and makes black audiences think,
"I had to do that same [bleep]
last week."
Don't forget the part
where the black person
bravely defies racist laws.
And then the white guy steps in
like he's some sort
of Goddamn hero.
-You should be ashamed
of yourselves, lady.
You know,
it's people like you --
-I can't go with you
standing up there are.
-Oh, okay.
-And one racist who's
so cartoonishly racist
that other racists
watch this movie and say,
"Well, at least,
I'm not that racist."
-Well, well, well,
look at what we have here.
If it ain't another
gobbedy-goo-goo
ga-ga-goo-goo-ga-doodle.
A gaga-gaga-gogle!
[ Barks ]
[ Barking continues ]
[ Speak gibberish ]
From the makers of
"Green Book," "Hidden Figures,"
"The Help," "The Blind Side,"
"Dangerous Minds," "Glory,"
"Cool Runnings,"
"Radio," "Hard Ball,"
"Ghosts of Mississippi,"
"The Principal,"
"A Time to Kill,"
"Freedom Riders,"
"Sunset Park,"
"The Air Up There"
and "Wild Cats."
-Hey, thanks for everything.
-You're welcome.
[ Chuckling ] Now, don't you go
falling in love with me.
-I won't...
because that doesn't
test well with audiences.
♪♪
-"People" magazine says,
"This movie is a triumph,"
and the black person
it's based on says,
"This is not at all
how it happened,"
and if you're a black person
hoping for the catharsis
of watching a black character
punch a racist,
you'll get the next
best thing...
-[ Grunts ]
-...the white guy
punching a racist.
-If I'd have done that,
they'd have locked me up
until I died.
-Plus, a scene where
the white guy is helpful
in a way that doesn't
advance the cause
of all black people...
just the one he's friends with.
-Huh?
♪♪
-It also have stuff like this.
-I know what it's like for you.
And there's nothing worse
than feeling like an outsider.
Like, one time...
when I was in junior high,
I got some toilet paper stuck
to the bottom of my shoe,
and the other kids, well...
you know how kids can be.
They called me "Mr. Poop Shoe."
I felt like it
went on for weeks,
but it was actually probably
only about five minutes
before someone told me,
and I took it off,
but, yeah.
I understand racism.
[ Laughter ]
-Featuring a scene
where the white character
introduces the black character
to something they definitely
already knew about.
-I'm gonna teach you about
a little something called jazz.
-And no "White Savior" movie
is complete
without a white woman
adopting a black person.
-I'm here to adopt you.
-Adopt me?
I'm older than you.
-You will no longer want
for anything in this world.
-Word?
Bye, children!
Hey, Mommy, what's for dinner?
-Well, I guess I'd have
to ask the chef.
-Chef?!
-Some movies examine
the complexities
of race relations in America.
This movie does not do that.
But according to "The Root,"
it does push a black
helplessness narrative
that paints black people as
passive in their own history.
Plus it's corny.
And you know this movie was
written by a white person
because the black person
becomes friends
with the racist.
-You know what, Loretta,
you're all right.
-Thanks, Earl.
For some reason,
earning your respect
is something I'm interested in.
-"White Savior."
In theaters this spring.
And coming soon,
the Rosa Parks story
told from the perspective
of a white guy
who was also on the bus --
"Rosa and Kevin."
♪♪
-Hey!
This seat's free.
[ Cheers and applause ]